Jon Stewart just went viral in a clip
that I think makes him look like a
complete hack and buffoon but the clip
has gone viral on the on the left as an
example of of Jon Stewart totally owning
the Republican Arkansas attorney general
with facts and Logic on this very point
take a listen
why would the state of Arkansas step in
to override
parents
Physicians
psychiatrists
endocrinologists who have developed
guidelines why would you override those
guidelines
well I think it's important that all of
those Physicians all of those experts
for every single one of them there's an
expert that says we don't need to allow
children to be able to take those
medications that there are many
instances where but you know that's not
true you know it's not for everyone
there's one there's these are the
established well I don't know that but
that's not true I don't know that then
why would you why would you pass a law
then if you don't if you don't know that
that's true wouldn't you well I know
that there are doctors let me let me try
and flip it a different way and see if
maybe this this can help in Arkansas if
you have pediatric cancer
and obviously we all want to protect
children I think we established that
earlier
whose guidelines do you follow for
Pediatric cancer
whose guidelines do you follow this is
his own you follow the doctors
so then if you follow the doctors on a
very long-standing well-established body
of medical literature on how to treat a
very specific ailment that will kill
your child then why don't you trust them
when they want to cut your child's penis
off
um do I do I even have to answer that
question by the way the very fact that
the so-called medical experts are now
advocating pumping little kids full of
cross-ex hormones and trying to mutilate
them into being the opposite sex
actually does make me less likely to
trust them on the cancer treatment and
on every other aspect of Medical Science
but do you see what Jon Stewart is
advocating here he's advocating a
complete blind allegiance to and faith
in the political establishment
not even just the medical experts
because as the Arkansas attorney general
rightly points out there are many
experts on the other side and Jon
Stewart doesn't even really quibble with
that he says well it's not one to one
there's not one of your experts for
every one of our experts which may or
may not be true sort of who cares he's
at least conceding the premise that yes
you conservatives the people who oppose
chopping off little kids genitals you
guys have some experts on your side but
we have other experts and anyway our
experts are the ones that are enshrined
in the political establishments you
should trust them a complete Blind Faith
ironic of course because Jon Stewart
presents himself as speaking truth to
power and the whole left presents itself
as being sort of counter-cultural and
fighting the entrenched Powers when in
fact they they are the only entrenched
power in the country
but imagine that
imagine imagine thinking that let's just
say Jon Stewart's being sincere for a
second
he is he is actually telling people not
to believe their own eyes not to use
their own brains not to use their own
reason not to not to trust anything that
happened before yesterday before today
why wouldn't you trust the experts I I
wouldn't trust the experts because they
are saying that boys can actually be
girls
that's why that's the proof that they're
not omniscient not necessarily correct
here not the Geniuses you're presenting
them to be the very fact that they're
saying that
is the proof that they are not
that they are not these people and John
Stewart actually makes a joke earlier in
this clip he says you know some people
used to make jokes about transgenderism
but those guys were totally wrong and
then he plays a clip of himself doing it
on his show but he says but now I've
been told by the political establishment
that's not true so I'm going to ignore
even what I used to think but just look
at the record here
the Prejudice of the people the wisdom
of repugnance of Ordinary People the
intuitions and natural inklings of
Ordinary People
in recent years has been proven much
much more reliable much much more
correct much much more trustworthy than
the fantasies and pronouncements of the
exalted established experts Boston
Children's Hospital not only just put
out an insane video on transgenderism
not only an incoherent video on
transgenderism but an internally in a
self-contradictory
incoherent video on transgenderism take
a listen
so most of the patients that we have in
the gems Clinic actually know their
gender usually around the age of puberty
but a good portion of children do know
as early as seemingly from the womb and
they will usually Express their gender
identity as very young children some as
soon as they can talk they might say
phrases such as I'm a girl or I'm a boy
or I'm going to be a woman or I'm going
to be a mom kids know very very early
children know that they're transgender
in the womb
children in the womb aren't children
they're just clumps of cells they're not
even human and they're not alive
those are two opinions that the libs
want us to hold simultaneously
what do you think the odds are that that
lady saying that supports abortion
a hundred fifty percent
I would bet I would bet a lot of money
that that lady's pro-abortion
I would bet my entire net worth that
the people who fall in line with her
argument broadly support abortion
and they support abortion because they
say usually the the mainstream
pro-abortion argument is oh it's not a
baby not human not alive not a person
when that suits their argument on
abortion but then when they want to
Peddle transgenderism they say not only
is it alive not only is it human not
only is it a person but it's actually
conscious and it's aware of gender
identity and the little blastula or
whatever stupid science jargony term
they want to use actually knows that
even though he looks like a boy he's
really a girl that's what and they want
you to believe that
that's what they
and when you raise any questions about
that they will brush you aside they'll
say oh you're not an expert you're an
idiot you don't know anything
but it's just arbitrary it's just
capricious it's it's the it's the exact
same thing as Dr fauci saying don't wear
the masks and then a week later wear the
masks you have to wear the masks what
changed I don't know shut up you stooge
you little sheep whatever I say I'm the
science so whatever I say is the truth
it's just it's the exact same thing and
that's all they ever say the the science
worship is just so preposterous
it's it's preposterous
in in the scientific terms that they're
using and it's Preposterous because
physical reality is not the Ultimate
Reality and we there's much more to talk
about
philosophy ethics theology all sorts of
things than just cells but even on the
level of science it's ridiculous today's
music Monday okay
we've got a a song
that was requested by one of the great
members of this show who will we will
see in the member block and uh my
producer Ben Davies has teed it up for
me he tells me I'm going to hate the
song but we'll see
the rest of the show begins now if you
don't want to miss it Well you certainly
don't want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us we will see you over at the
member block
[Music]
foreign
[Music]